look what we've got today the brand new
iphone 12
in purple they just announced this at
their spring loaded event
i'm so excited about this because do you
know what my favorite color is other
than pink and black
purple they did have a purple phone
previously it was the iphone 11 which we
have
here and not gonna lie to you i forgot
which phone this was i was like was this
a 10r is this a 10 what it is the 11.
i did in fact confirm with google so i'm
excited to see what this color looks
like in comparison to this one
oh oh okay it's kind of a very similar
purple to our other purple friend it's
like a little bit more
saturated like if you were in photoshop
and you just you know opened up the
saturation and you were just like
that's what you get okay inside the box
we've got the usual suspects we've got
our usbc
to lightning cable and sim card ejector
and a little apple sticker
and here's our little phone here we go
like a brand new phone like there's
nothing better than a new iphone i like
that the iphone 12 went back to the
squared edges
so you guys can see here on the iphone
11 the difference between
those edges i like the squared off edges
so much more because i do feel like you
get a little bit more screen real estate
and they were able to kind of make it a
little bit thinner like this just feels
kind of like a little chunky this feels
slim
and nice but i really really like this
color
look at that look at the difference this
could quite possibly be my shortest
youtube video that i've ever posted
that phone's like it wants to be purple
but it's not like committing to be
purple
you're right but the thing is this fit
in sort of with the theme of all the
rest of the colors
because they were more of like the
lighter pastel colors but this one also
kind of fits into
the theme of all the colors that we have
now
so we've got the purple the blue the
green the product red
the white and the black actually i
happen to have
the green here like they're kind of just
keeping them all in sort of that same
color family
here's the black iphone 12 you can't
even see it
on my desk but it's there this purple
also comes in the iphone 12
mini which this has been a really fun
phone for me
if i'm going on a hike or something this
is always the phone that i take unless i
want to have some zoom photos but if i
know i'm just going on a hike just
purely for exercise not to create
content this is the phone that i take
it's just such a small device that it
fits in my pocket
and it's almost like i don't even have
it there but i do
so here it is in size comparison to
the 12. it really is significantly
smaller
then let's show you guys what this looks
like
in comparison to the 12 pro max like
this is such a big phone
so to go from this phone to this phone
when i'm going on a hike or something
is significant look at you guys your
eyes are like a happy little family
so i'd love to know from you guys what
do you guys think of the new purple
color
i think it's really really beautiful i
like the fact that it is way more
saturated than the previous iphone 11
color
i hate when the yerba is
gone it's like
so this is the purple case that they
came out with i love
magsafe the magsafe cases everything
about them are awesome
let's open this up i love the color it
matches my body
this was of course i planned this i
oh coordinated look at that i like that
it's a darker
kind of purple too so it's a little more
contrasty
hey tyler can you see me no
look what i got this is the magsafe duo
charger this has been one of my most
favorite
little accessories in a really long time
i love that it just
folds up just like that i take this with
me pretty much everywhere i go
i haven't been traveling as much as i
used to but i did do a three week road
trip
and this has been amazing because i take
this i bring
my lightning cable charger and i'm set
to go
to charge my phone charge
my apple watch i don't know it's kind of
like a like a big like wafer cracker or
something that you just wanna
don't do that covet also this has
absolutely nothing to do with this video
but
i just bought this this is an aura band
and this is something that will allow
you to be able to track your body
composition
it'll tell you if you're dehydrated and
it's kind of just an
added little bonus to be able to get
more metrics about what's happening with
your body so i'm super excited about
this i just got it i'll put a link in
the description
if you want to check it out as well and
i even tested it out on
a recent episode of our podcast if you
want to check that out it's
youtube.combrain
i've been enjoying this and i think one
of the most important things
especially in this day of not being able
to get into doctor's offices
just to be able to kind of monitor your
own health so in case there is something
going on you'll be able to have this
backlog of data to be able to take to
your doctor and be like look this is
what's normal
this is not normal help something's
wrong
anyway i do plan on doing a video about
this entirely but i kind of want to just
test it out a little bit more
and i don't know get more data about
this
this vessel of mine well thank you guys
for watching this is just a quick video
i wanted to show you the new iphone 12
in the purple with this beautiful new
purple case
i love this color i love the color of
the case and
i guess that's that's the end of the
video if you guys enjoyed this video or
if you want to see some more videos
about some cool apple tech that's coming
out be sure to hit subscribe
like this video and leave a comment and
let me know what your favorite iphone 12
color is currently
and i will see you guys in the next one
bye